hello hello my God that was stressful it
was so stressful Harris has run
off he's evaporated he's gone for a whiz
the spirit of Brad R has come to his
bedroom and like beating him up he's
gone yeah it was 100% a whiz Break um
Tony sorry about that M this the the
debate ran on longer than we were
expected but we are live
now
how' you enjoy that
Harris uh it was fun I that threw me for
a loop whenever uh I thought the opening
statement was another question
everything's just worded so similarly it
threw me off uh but besides that it was
fun as hell I I no no I didn't think it
was I I didn't make a mistake I was
testing you yeah we had a 30 minute
meeting yesterday to discuss how we were
going to do this stream and we still
messed it up so I think the simple fix
would be when we're making the questions
we should just add numbers to them
instead of bullet points so we actually
know I did on my
side yeah there was there was no there
was no numbers if there was numbers it
probably would have been better
Jan hello Jenny how are you I did mean
to say hello to you during but I was
moderating we were were so I'm gonna I
did I
did she the only comment I highlighted
throughout the entire thing that was the
acknowledgement just hello
right um but yeah I I really enjoyed
that and I didn't mean to um be
argumentative with you Harris but you
were wrong all the way through it was
amazing it was just like it was just
like it was you know like I was it like
I was arguing the
opposite um it's like like somebody
that's like it's like you decided to be
wrong for like an hour and all the way
through it was
brilliant did he decide did you decide
for him though I think there's a caveat
that should be added into
that good Jenny I'm glad yeah you picked
the um oh yeah the
ribs um yes delivered by himself um I
love how full of himself Jay is full of
myself I'm just it's not my fault I'm
this
awesome I mean my mate genuinely wants
um he was um he somebody had a go at him
and he said um it's not my fault 95% of
the time I'm the cleverest person in the
room that's full of yourself I only
think I'm the cleverest person in the
room like 80% of the time something like
that that's only when you're in the room
with your kids isn't it yeah pretty much
pretty much um but but um I'm not full
of myself but I am opinionated I think
it's
David's bringing up a good point in
there as much as I do like judar Binks
from like a child perspective
uh lazy suay I have invited to come and
say hi but I don't blame her if she
doesn't want if she's on a lazy
day yeah uh but but yeah George Lucas
brought the prequels
back you're the only
person you could argue actually that um
they went downhill well no George Lucas
brought back the like the J Jar Binks
Trilogy and they were awful that's what
yeah when other people got involved you
could argue they stayed awful um but I
don't know the theories that Jar Binks
was actually a sa Lord and then that got
changed I love
stuff yeah because that would have
been is there Harris was there anything
that I brought up that made you go yeah
fair enough because actually I think
there's a couple of points you brought
up then I'm like that's a dum good
argument no just because I mean I'm I'm
in the just because I love Brad Wright
I'd love for him to showrun uh I I
brought up points that I didn't think I
was going to bring up that I was like oh
well that kind of makes sense I I
convinced myself of my own points a
little bit more but only like in the
sense of like uh of of really that
closing argument of like what the hell
did I say at the very end
um it was about five minutes ago haris I
know I'd smoked too much weed i' give me
45 minutes and I will know it I haven't
smoked anything today either but just
the shortterm memory loss is the bad
part the one downside
generally
uh I ended it with saying oh because he
he hasn't done a show since 2018 that
that's the thing that really I think is
the biggest not ultimatum for me but the
thing that made me like oh wait I didn't
even think about that till I started
saying it was I mean lit literally
Mandalorian changed the way TV happened
and that was the last time that was when
his last show finished airing you know
good it can be started amazing but oh
well it and it could go both ways it
could be a good thing or it could be a
bad thing it just depends who's making
it and and the team you know I mean
Brad's talked about having the whole
team involved before and the team's
really what makes it I I I know this
whole debates about the showrunner but
like that's that's why I was trying to
say like Robert Cooper all these names
like we need the Old Guard there or or
people that know it or grew up like if
you don't have the Old Guard you need
two dozen mats you know like you you
need someone like not not that older age
that will be going like oh yeah but the
people that grew up with it and
literally have it in grained into their
memory banks like that's that's a
different
like T of course M like a not t enough
that you can do that
um Matt
who just be like take your opinion out
of it who who had the best argument me
or
me
what I don't want to say you
now I get the popular vote later
on heads for o win tals for
Harris
[Music]
for me so for me your your arguments
were better because I agree with you I
agree we all we right we all agree we
all are we all on the same side of the
coin it's just Harry's got the short end
of the the stick here and he ended up he
had to argue the wrong one yeah this is
my I can't I can't say that I agreed
with anything Harris said he did make
make some good points granted but so
does every debate like there's always
some good points on either side
but Laura don't start
But
ultimately I agree I agree
that we do we do need Brad in some
fashion if we can honestly say they here
they go do do we want him to show run or
do we just want him
there I mean because right in Star Trek
um Gan Roden br's kid is there as a um
uh a consultant right and they've
basically given him the job because of
his name because he's a
Rodenburg Productions and it was always
there to appease fans that's why they
did it but he's got absolutely no power
um that the idea is he's supposed to
step in if they like really screw Cannon
up and he says he's had to do it once or
twice maybe and I'm like well you
weren't there for Discovery season one
then were you because that was a [__]
show from beginning to end um
if if they just bring Brad wght in as a
consultant right with no real power is
that worse than him not being involved
at all I think he has no power if he has
no power then yes for me uh because he
should have
some uh input into the direction that it
goes I
think ability to jump in we should have
the ability to jump in and let's say
it's Mark Fergus and Hulk Cosby or let's
just say it's someone else completely
different right they they they're gonna
have their own ideas but Brad should be
there to go actually you can't do this
because of this and have the right to
change things if they break the rules
that he
established
Harris somebody uh Bob said maybe they
can get Chris Rock to play Jack in the
SG I just started laughing Sor threw me
off I want Selen to do oh
please and then we're gonna get Will
Smith's like ball to come and slap him
in the face that' be good oh that' be
awesome oh one of the goal
yeah um but but Harris I mean if he came
on as a consultant with no power and it
is basically just lip service to the
fans is that a problem I think that's
kind of where he he should be because
there's no such thing as just lip
service to fans and if he's involved as
a consultant it's Brad Wright it's not
like roddenberry's kid coming in here
doing something like that it's Brad
Wright if he's if he is a producer of
some sort because that's what a
consultant's going to be he credited as
a producer of some sort so if he is a
producer of some sort he's gonna be on
set he's going to be something and if
there is an old guard if Amazon has
taken the time and due diligence to
bring back back so not necessarily Old
Guard Rider producing room kind of thing
the Old Guard cast
wise who do you think they're going to
listen to if Brad Wright's involved at
all he's got power Maybe not maybe not
showrunner power but that's okay if if
he's a consultant he's truly a
consultant they can't involve him and
say they can't pull the PJ they can't
say Peter Jackson and be like one
T2 perfect time to for the Peter Jackson
reference I'm just saying that was that
was very great timing there uh but but
they they can't pull a let's call Peter
Jackson and then hang up on him if they
call him at all there is no hanging up
if if he's involved at all there is no
hanging up where they were like new not
new line whoever was making the ring the
power uh show were saying oh what's up
Peter Jackson can we get some advice
this this and this these are ideas and
then two phone calls later if there is a
second phone call later Brad Wright's
involved you know uh
probably not with the making of the
Bible making of the series but if he's
already there
um that just if he's there as a
consultant in season one or season one
and
two who's to say he couldn't be riding
for season two or three or four If he if
he starts out with the smaller amount of
power who's to say wait a second this is
the guy that everybody actually pays
attention to on set or this is the guy
that people pay attention to in the
writer room let's let's
argument should be made that Brad
is no knowing that Brad might watch this
Brad is getting
older old old time he's so old a whole
62 try not to be offensive getting older
and it's a joke because of his comment
on if you follow us on Twitter
tvori it's a joke because of the comment
he made when we shared this video but go
on he's an old old man that's what
you're saying right he's a he's a
terribly old man yes okay whatever Terri
old he I think he should be involved at
least very early on and then maybe if he
steps away later on that's that's fine
but I would like him to be involved at
least in the first season so we know not
just so his names attached to it and old
all the old fans would be like oh Brad
Wright's making Stargate again so we
know
it at
least Poots the coordinates in the ship
and would know it's going to go in the
right direction maybe it stays off every
now and then but we know generally it's
going in the right
direction I think that's fair the I mean
the reality of how MGM and Amazon does
things is that Brad's right and I'm
sorry guys after all that argument we've
just had the reality is Brad W will not
be showrunning this new series he just
won't because mg M won't be
producing the show so there will be a
production company that produces the
show in cooperation with MGM and Amazon
and that production company will will be
the showrunner this is like Star Trek
now with secret hideout produces the
show in cooperation with CBS Studios and
so therefore the show runner is hired by
secret hideout it's not hired
by why did you mute me
though that's just saying what
happened so the reality is it's this is
a bu business decision and Brad r as an
executive producer is is probably the
best we're GNA in reality
get but as an executive producer he
comes in with an element of authority if
he comes in just as a
consultant my question really is is that
there just to appease fans and in that
cas should we be more pissed off
because for me that means
nothing I'll go back to the argument I
made in the debate right there is I just
think s even suggesting that fans need
appeasement before so I I I I don't even
like honestly all that I mean for I I I
just think it it insults both the studio
and us as a fan base as well uh I I
truly I I I think you just got to trust
and see what happens where you did just
lay out I where the the contracts work a
little bit closer to Star Trek uh the
way new Trek is but that doesn't mean
it's going to end up like new Trek and
Amazon has taken like the time like
we've been clamoring about this for two
years like we we want it you know like
we wish they would have announced it a
year and a half ago but they're they're
doing their due diligence and I I do
appreciate that and I
I it's not even they're doing their due
diligence it's just that all the
dominoes have not Fallen in the right
place up and then some some like cats
come along and knock the wrong one
over um I'm I'm just there just saying
here that that argue we argued we need
him and I'm saying that if Stargate is
going to be successful I genuinely
believe they need Brad Wright involved
and I think the best way to do is to
make him a
showrunner but there is then a reality
involved in this I want Manchester
United to go out and buy um Pelle it is
a 25 old Pelle but the reality is
pelle's dead
possibly but you know that's the so what
I want and what I think Stargate needs
to be successful and unfortunately there
is then a reality that goes with it so
my argument is still what I generally
believe and valid and you know and
actually if Amazon have got any sense
they will give him a serious role in
this but the reality is someone like
penguin in a Parker is going to produce
this TV show in partnership with MGM it
won't be if Brad wght wants to be the
showrunner we might have to create
another production company to do it yeah
um and I don't know if that's gonna
happen um I've seen the isss movie and
it's it's it's boring as you you saw it
yeah God it's boring I saw it about a
month ago actually oh really okay
because the I keep I've been seeing all
kinds of reviews the first half I I keep
hearing that it's really good and then
the second half it just gets dumb boring
like it just turns into something that
it shouldn't have been it it it's it
feels like it's going to be one thing
and then about like yeah yeah about I
would say in the second maybe halfway
through the second act it switches and
becomes something else and just got this
is just stupid it just don't work but
yeah I saw an early version about a
month
ago not worth checking out or worth
checking out I was debating see okay go
um one of the things we did talk about
though was Canon right a lot yeah and
actually I was watching an interview
with the guy and I've forgotten his name
sorry I should have written it down but
it was a guy that um wrote window
opportunity which most people would
agree as one of the best Stargate
episodes ever made and he was talking
about when he was brought
in um he was basically ased you know
write a couple of episodes and they
pitched a few episodes to
Brad they'd never watched Stargate
before they'd watched they what they did
was they went and watched two or three
episodes just to get a feel for it and
then they wrote a few episodes and
pitched them to Brad and Robert Cooper
um and they then went on to write window
of opportunity in a few other episodes
which are considered some of the best
episodes ever written you know some of
the fan favorites you know so my point
is I think sometimes somebody new can
come
in and maybe that is a new showrunner um
and and and it can be
better and then maybe bring in Amanda
tappin or somebody like that to to do it
that was the rumor that we heard a long
time ago that um Amazon were considering
getting Amanda ta to come in as maybe
not show runner but as an executive
producer or something
else what do you think Matt is I mean
can it sometimes be better not having
the old card fresh
blood yeah well at the example you just
gave someone with basically no
experience so a fresh perspective coming
in and watching a couple of episodes if
if they wrote the best episodes that
exist it's just that's the proof isn't
proof in the pudding
[Music]
but is that not is that not more rare
would be my argument is that is that
something that happens once in a blue
moon and this is just one of those freak
moment things where someone new has come
in wrot written something and it just so
happens to be one of the best
episodes um that's raid by fans or or or
is it just genuinely they had a fresh
perspective and they were able to
capture something that someone who had
been there quite well hadn't yet done it
is a rarity for that to actually happen
but it's the only reason it's a rarity
is because the people that come in with
A New Perspective and new stuff don't
take the time to go back and and do like
the necessary research per se or like
there's the acolyte show coming out this
year for Star Wars A lot of people are
worried about because Leslie hedin was
saying like oh I don't really care about
Star Wars never really seen a whole
bunch but we're going to do it kind of
like in our own way kind of deal and you
know bunch of Star Wars people are not
very happy about that being said but
kind of the same thing like hey uh
Gilroy wasn't the biggest Star Wars guy
and he was brought in for rogue one and
Andor it's amazing uh it might not feel
inherently Star Wars the same way
everything else does but it has that new
new kind of tonality to it new feel to
it while still inherently feeling star
warsy and being uh succinctly in that
world I don't know uh it just the person
coming in there the reason it's rare is
there's a lack of respect to the source
material a lot of times and not
necessarily lack of respect a lack of uh
willfulness to go in and truly earn the
respect that you need to write something
like
that it's just it's just yeah ignorance
to the source material yeah or not even
ignorance like well ignorance but like a
willful willful Blissful ignorance
that's the better way of
saying I I think second W's got a point
there that um yeah I mean Star Trek has
changed a lot since Discovery it's like
they did the first season of Discovery
and the fan reaction was so negative
that they sort of went ah we better
change that and I think there's been an
evolution through Star Trek
over got seven years eight years since
since Discovery season one came out um
and 14 they're going in the right
direction and I do generally think
they're going in the right direction um
they're listening to fans they're trying
to keep with Canon what I'm saying is I
don't want Stargate to have to go
through five years of evolution to get
back to where it should have been at the
beginning and that's what n Star Trek
has doing it's they came in with
completely new ideas and they had to go
back
to do BR brager St Trek of 15 years ago
we don't need we don't need that um we
need need this to hit the ground running
from the beginning and we what we cannot
have is a showrunner to come in with
brand new ideas and go you know what the
gold um are gonna have a
completely different thing all right
this is a good question
yeah that's also another I mean Harris
you I thought actually you brought a
really good point up there and Jenny is
Spang
on new Stargate has to attract new fans
it has to
you cannot just do a TV show for a
skaters we'll go watch it anyway and we
keep saying this we'll go watch it
anyway it's got to attract new fans
somehow how do you do that that's my
biggest worry with that's that's kind of
my my point behind like the whole
um the the formulaic aspect of Stargate
and how it where it it Brad did try to
evolve it and I I hated saying anything
against that because he did actively he
was trying to evolve Stargate with
Atlantis and with uh
universe but the biggest issue is he
didn't actually evolve it he just
tweaked it it was just a tweak there was
tweaks instead of a true Evolution for
the show there were there were parts of
an evolution for the show I think
Universe was more of an evolution than
than Atlantis for sure it's season two
for damire what what you were saying in
your debate about having less of a
formulaic and more episodic and more
like Arc driven um like kind of content
that that is what SG was trying to do it
wasn't it wasn't just like monster of
the
week um there was an overall AR and
there were like two two or three like
two or three part episodes because there
was like a thing that was that was going
wrong and it just it just wasn't
resolved in in one episode like it
always was in
sg1 that's that that that's that's
that's not 100% correct they weren't
always resolved in SG one in one one or
two episodes but largely monster of the
week episode it was there's a thing
we've got an incursion there's a there's
a deadly virus and then at the end of
the episode oh it's gone but with SGU
they they just they they flipped that
completely and and it wasn't gone the
threat always remained there was always
something and I think that was the
evolution yeah Jose just made a point
there that the original showns didn't
didn't nearly cast David huet to be fair
they wanted David huet there was a Prue
with Executives kept pushing for a
different character and a different sort
of character um one point in that video
that I did last week was um they sort of
said that um they had their one to five
people they wanted for the character and
the executives had a completely opposite
there's their one to five was their five
to one
um Brad Wright and Robert Cooper wanted
David huet they kept saying we need
somebody like David huet but the
executives wanted a different type of
character so we were just lucky that
they won the arum didn't he didn't he uh
audition for another role and said you
too much like
McKay like he he was going to be a
different role he would like be
different character completely and he
just but he was auditioning for a whole
new Ro and they said you're too much
like McKay and he's like yeah because I
am
McKay well yeah I mean Jenny Sten talks
here about there are about 300 act
300,000 active Stargate fans worldwide
right now and that is um I mean based on
things like Facebook and all these sorts
of things that people actively are
interested in Facebook right now in
starget right now sleeping GI we make
that Millions though because any new
show has to be
Millions it has to draw in in the in the
US 10 million viewers yeah you know or
more I mean just put in perspective real
fast the Ahsoka show was deemed not very
successful uh numbers wise and it was 28
29 million people watching the first
episode I believe in America I believe
world I would think worldwide worldwide
28 million isn't great no no no no but
that's just to to bring it from 300,000
to we need 28 29 million to be like one
of those top 10 neelon rating shows kind
of deal because that's what you want
Star to be you wanted to be in that top
10 neelen maybe
not content beew 28 million
times yeah I mean any new show that will
drag back people that had forgotten
about starting that love it and will
come back but you
know 1.5 million you gotta start
somewhere honestly in the US we need
that in the UK alone you know but they
don't ex they don't really care about
viewers what they will care about is
when they then do um if if they see a
little bit of a spike in subscribers and
when they asked those subscribers did
you subscribe to MGM plus let's be
honest that's where this is going to end
up did you sub subribe to MGM plus to
watch Stargate and enough people say yes
they're happy if they get a million new
subscribers to MGM plus and and 90% of
those people say we subscribed for
Stargate Amazon will do a
backflip that' be very very happy with
that they won't care and then they'll
show it on it then they'll show it on
Prime six months
later I'm just I I'm not gung-ho about
MGM I just I think it's such a wrong
decision to even remotely put it
anywhere in the realm of MGM Plus
instead of
prime um though fortunately though this
show is probably going to be from the
most recent thing I've been listening to
it's it's it's going to be an MGM Plus
in the United States it may not be and
probably here in the UK as well because
MGM they're about to start pushing MGM
plus big time in Europe where they
haven't really up till now they've only
really pushed in you know how hard it is
to subscribe to MGM Plus
it's really really easy I did it by
accident
once you go into if you go into the app
and you click on anything that is MGM
plus you press how do I watch this
there's no button to buy it at all in
the app you have to go on the website
most people will be using a
mobile um well yeah maybe
um I mean I I'm hoping I'm wrong on on
it'll appear on MGM plus my
what well I tell you what I actually
think what's going to happen is we're
going to get a movie anyway I actually
think that that seems to be where we're
going the argument for MGM
is they want a series because they see
that as their way of pushing to the next
level if they want to continue growing
MGM Plus getting a series like Stargate
is the way to do it and that's their
argument that's the argument they made
back in
August um so if we get a series and we
don't know if they have or not and and
Jordan noticed you you've asked that
question a couple times I will ask I
will answer it in a second um if if we
get a series I think MGM MGM will be
screaming for it to premiere on MGM plus
and from what MGM plus and Michael
Wright and thing was talking about that
interview a couple of months ago the the
plan would be seem to be it would go to
MGM plus and then when just before
season two comes out it'll go on Prime
and then season two will get MGM plus
again um and that's how they'll do it um
and that seems to be something they're
they're thinking about they really want
to push MGM pluses like that this thing
but it depends I I actually don't think
that's what's going to happen though I
still think it's going to be a movie
everything I'm hearing is that Amazon
we're not convinced it's going to be a
movie I I still think a movie is best
but MGM plus no matter what at the end
of the day it's just another barrier
people have to get through before they
actually are able to walk watch the show
it's just such a bad idea it's such a
bad idea and I I is it who I always say
the wrong I always say HBO like
executive names when I'm trying to say
the MGM people uh Mike Michael Wright
right Mike right yeah Mike right I get
wanting to push MGM plus that's your
baby you want it to grow but at the
behest of of a show that and the reason
he wants it wants Stargate is because he
knows how pivotal it is not just for
Amazon as a company but I mean for
Amazon as a company
like do you think putting a barrier in
front of that's a good idea dude I just
sorry Mike right I just don't there
there's no logical argument for that
that actually makes sense numerically at
the end of the day I don't think I think
it just makes sense as well that again I
we talked about how MGM are not and
Amazon are not announcing Stargate right
now because when the strikes ended they
then had to get everything up and
rolling again um but also there is an
issue this that they knew
these these were this was coming mean
they knew they were going to slim down
certain areas like Jenny says they lost
certain
resources they then need to get that all
set up before they can announce and
before they can move people around to to
get the thing because remember this is
all about people and you know as well so
I do think that's another reason why
thing but Amazon still lock in argument
movie series Brad noad young yeah um it
was not resolved by the left I I think
the layoffs are just another reason why
what I'm hearing is this decision is not
going and and the most thing Reon I'm
hearing is MGM Plus have not released
their um publicly not released their um
uh development slate like they were
expected to I'm hearing that it has been
sort of spread among certain people in
the industry but it's not being publicly
released and one of the reasons is it's
not complete because they don't actually
know what they're doing um or or they
they know what they want to do but
they've got a get these things sorted
out first and it's just one more
business decision delaying a show that
we desperately want but it's not just
delaying Stargate it's delaying RoboCop
Legally Blond 3 the thing we actually
care about on this
channel projects Amazon spent nearly 10
billion dollar on MGM plus and they've
done nothing with it yet
nothing and all these things are just in
the way in the way in the way the the
thing that honestly like RoboCop's the
thing that flabbergast me the most for I
don't know what word I'm looking for but
flabber gash is the one I'll stick with
um like Stargate it makes sense for them
to hold back a little bit make sure
they're doing it right make sure
everyone's going to be happy or at least
if they're not going to be happy it
reaches the right compromise where
everybody might not be happy but
everybody's got a slice of the pie where
they're GNA at least be able to enjoy it
uh Legally Blond three is kind of that
thing where like okay they can just drop
it whenever they want to it's not I
don't know if they've even filmed it or
not yet but that's that's an easy thing
where they can at least like they got
Reese Witherspoon to jump in there and
they have like all you got to do is at
least get the project going on that
where RoboCop I think is that thing
where that's just it's it's I don't know
why it is I mean obviously for us for
sci-fi people but RoboCop is a household
name and really there's no reason for it
to be it it hasn't been on screen in 30
years really the better version the only
true version that I guess we got the the
reboot but that doesn't even really
count you know like it's not great
there's no reason for RoboCop to be the
household name that it is and because it
is the household name that it is why not
announce that you're working on it just
to have something some kind of momentum
for the company itself you don't need to
announce all the other projects of
course people enjoy a slate but just say
hey we're working on something we we're
not stag we're not just sitting in the
water over here we're we're paddling you
know I mean that is again that is the
rumor I'm hearing that Amazon top people
have been going to MGM plus and not just
MJ but jennif s runs obviously both and
go why aren't we doing anything with
this entity that we spent 9 billion on
um what where where is the results I
know I know we've had the strikes but
come on we bought all of this IP and
we're not doing anything with
it come on let's announce something and
I know there's things like they've got
to get the the the studio space and
they've got to I mean I mean Amazon have
gone from being a really small company
that was basically financing movies and
they actually now want to make it
themselves that's not a little thing to
try to do no not at all that is there is
there is Big projects on it and Amazon
are trying to cut costs like all of the
other Studios everybody Paramount have
said all of their stuff's got to Cost
Less 30% less than what it cost last
year so and and Amazon are exactly the
same boat they've massively overspent
and now they've got to sort themselves
out um
so yeah 6p was assigned after the
purchase all existing franchises went to
Amazon creative Studios yeah all new
series stayed with MGM creative
Studios yeah so um anything existing MGM
anything new was going to go over to
Amazon and now we've got all of these
layoffs and nobody knows where they're
at again you know and it's just like
started again
um yeah Mike right though is again Mike
right Mike right Chris uttinger both
survived but they have several different
respon MGM Mike right isn't just a head
of MGM plus he's the head of two or
three other things as well and he's got
his fingers in lots of Pies Amazon like
moving people around as well and it's
you know it's
confusing um penguin and a Parker
nothing has changed since the last time
I mentioned this but so because Jordan
has asked me a couple of times in the in
the
questions um Jen if you've heard
anything new please let me know the last
thing I heard was that there was
conversations about a new contract for
them to go from development because they
did a development contract when they
were doing development work uh a year
ago um and there were conversations um
during the strikes about um sort of like
a new contract to start actually writing
scripts Etc but all I heard was there
was there was Whispers of it I never
heard anything more I've basically heard
nothing from um firm on penguin and a
Parker for a year now um since the
conversations ended last
Christmas um I have heard other
production companies names uh knocked
around including like imagin and a
couple of others so but there seems to
be still rumors but nothing nothing
solid nothing like we had before um no
more Jordan peels coming along no
nothing like that but the director I'm
told they know who the director's going
to be um that was before they seemed to
from the last thing I
heard the um um one of the people I
talked to got sacked as
well yeah get back to us as soon as you
do um so the last thing I heard was when
Jordan Peele was being considered and
they had him in and they had a chat with
him Etc um they had four or five people
in they picked a director oh oh wow and
they have apparently have a script for a
movie but the but then then they
actually just sat on the back burner
while they're sorting all their other
problems out in a very simplistic form
so it's it's ready to go it's just
there's so many other things that
they've got to
do because of the strikes because of
redundancies because trying to figure
out budgets because they're trying to
get Studio space and they're trying to
get their own rather than using other
people's which is cheap all of these
things and not happening quickly you
know and that's why people like I want
to say Bob Hoskins but that's not his
name
Mario yeah Hopkins is is not happy and
he wants it I don't think he's from what
I heard was it's not pissed that it's
happening he's like okay fine but what
what are we doing about it okay these
are the problems fine what are we doing
about it and come on can we do something
um so yeah let's see what happens but
apparently there are a couple of but
that most recently I think it was um let
me just double check the well I like the
fact that the director talk is still
even on the table because that means
it's most likely gonna be a movie at
least in my mind that's that's that's
nice that was the most recent
conversation but obviously during the
strikes everything sort of got put back
in the air
again um yeah imagine which is the
company that's owned by Ron Howard and
somebody else apparently they were there
was conversations with them ooh ooh ooh
ooh ooh oh you know who's just kind of
started directing the last few years
specifically in the Mandalorian uh who
would probably be involved a little bit
in the Imagine company if it's a Ron
Howard company who would probably be a
great
director freaking Bryce Dallas Howard
our episodes of the Mandalorian are by
far like there there might be like it's
Rick fwa and Bryce Dallas Howard who
tend to have the best episode to Mando
uh even in the new season she had the
best episode I think in the whole season
typically uh uh that she she'd be pretty
darn good honestly I'd never even
thought about that I would think if
somebody like imagin Steps in then I
think it's very possible that actually
penguin and Parker just did the
development work and then because
everything's gone on and on and on um
they've stepped away and they're going
to concentrate on other things and then
somebody like another company's going to
step in the problem
is my sources won't necessarily know
that I I have some that might find out
but if it's all going on in a different
company those conversations are going to
be limited and we're not going to know
the first thing we'll know is there's an
announcement because it's not going
because the conversations aren't going
on at MGM does that make sense it's
going on externally you know there's um
somebody else would be going that's
something you know
so just just for the sake of just the
thought
process if it is a movie and you just
two I mean let's let's try to be
realistic it's not necessarily A spiel
or a scorsi or or even a Chris Nolan or
somebody like that if you could just
pull a director out of out of your ARS
down there and say here here who it is
who's it gonna be who who's your
director for Stargate the movie the new
movie i' I'd almost quite like it to be
somebody that I that hasn't done a lot
maybe I know I know that's sort of like
that was the that was the argument
against rings of power that oh these
people don't know what they're doing I'm
almost like I want a name I don't know
and then you go oh they did that and
they did this and they did someone else
and you like oh man that was brilliant
um if it is a big name if is somebody
you know his name and that that what
kind of made me nervous about when
Jordan Peele apparently was having
conversation the guy that directed The
Creator as well Gareth Edwards that's
that's one of the two names that came to
mind and I also
like was apparently what in that
conversation um I'd be I'd be cool with
that I'd be like I want a name I don't
necessarily know but then when you go oh
yeah oh my God they did that amazing
yeah let's go for that and but there are
so many directors out there that either
visually brilliant or story-wise are
brilliant I want somebody that's
story-wise brilliant which is what my
argument against like somebody like JJ
Abrams who I don't think is a Bad
director but I think he's visually a
good director I don't I think it's style
over substance I want somebody that's
substance you know JJs is kind of like
Snider before Zack Snider was Snider but
just in like a little different of a way
that style over I was quite excited
about Jordan peal because I was thinking
that man he will not mess around with
the story it'll have something my only
concern is Will there'll be an agenda
with it it's not necessarily agenda I
disagree with but um he does want to say
things about his um say things about he
believes in a story and I'm like
sometimes it overtakes a story but um
but I think I think he loves MGM he
loves things like Stargate apparently he
he loves people that are involved in
Stargate and I think he did a good good
job but um but that's he's moved on to
his new project now anyway so it sounds
like it's not didn't happen so um horror
project with Marlon wein yeah I think um
Jenny makes a good point there that God
of War has become a big thing and
apparently penguin and AP Parker were
going to split it and it was going to be
Hawk HBY on one side and Mark Fergus on
the other and then they were apparently
trying to hire new wrers and things they
were building up towards doing it um but
then nearly a year ago that went very
quiet so I don't think it happened I
think it's moved onto a different
production company now but I don't know
who and if it ends up being somebody
like
imagin I don't think that's a bad
thing no honestly as much as the penguin
Parker people are great that's just
what's sprad him thin that's spread them
maybe a little too thin cuz God of War
or something that I I never played the
games cuz PlayStation exclusive and I'm
always just played Xboxes but people
adore that stuff like adore it and it's
it's got some intricate it's mythology I
mean it's got intricate story that you
really want to get right so yeah you
know he is a good listener isn't the
elbow he's that's why I love him so much
he just listens to what I say and nods
and then but if he starts talking Jay
does say shut up Matt very very
quickly um yeah um but yeah when we
start getting into this seers yeah um
yeah they lack they they are they lack
Studio space but they are buying new
studio space all the time and they're
doing these long-term rents with um with
um Hackman group so they they don't own
any they um rent loads but it's all
long-term
rents so yeah
anyway no he's he's having a
rest mediating difficult but anyway
we're going to say good night Matt stop
doing what you're doing I can see you I
can see you I can see you stop it there
we go so your director be fast it's been
a
long um uh they don't they're investors
in in the Hackman group
apparently um God award politics man
standing is PMP it's just put it in
whole due to
politics it's yeah I mean because we
haven't actually moved forward on God of
War for 12 month
um so that's still ex sa in development
so yeah
um and she's just text me saying I'm a
good
listener
a and you and you're also hung like a
donkey apparently I don't know anyway
you weren't supposed to to say that
publicly no one's supposed to know I've
shown
you old men are always the best lovers I
hear um right but boys that was
genuinely a brilliant a brilliant debate
Harris you didn't let me bully you well
of course
not it was that was so much fun that was
fun screw my notes up throw them
away um hand on heart who won who won
the argument who had the best argument
not just like who had the you know like
because obviously I had the the Brad
considering Harris had to argue with
something he doesn't believe in I
thought he argued pretty well so
he did actually didn't he came with a
couple of good points I was about to say
I don't know if anybody won overall
technically I think it just would be
that depend on the points honestly for
this one was just a it was
specific yeah it was fun it was fun um
yeah that was excellent guys thank you
Carrie thank you everybody else that
jumped in as well the comments like I
said we had like 400 comments while we
were on which is brilliant I didn't read
any of them I'll go back and have a look
um we ball guys are great between the
she
a lot of the comments are about my
hat can't make a decision the moderating
Hat hang on let me moderate this got
moderate
this
yes guys thank you so much um and you
guys again you put in put in the time to
make the argument and it's really good
we're going to do another one of these
sort of debates in a couple of weeks I
want to do Star Trek versus Star Wars
but we got think about how
to so real quick just while we have
people in here as well secular monk I
think is the guy that brought it up
earlier uh or or I think secular monk
might be a lady if I remember correctly
I don't know secular monk the person uh
brought it up earlier and uh they they
said we needed to get R&B on the show to
talk Star Trek Robert Meer Bernett at
some point uh I think y'all know who
that is uh he's he's just a great guy on
YouTube um he he'd be a good person to
try to get into like he's a big trekky
so if maybe you know we talked about the
idea of like getting other people to
come collaborate with us and do like a
debate kind of style from that he might
be a good person to jump at like from
the get-go and get on the Star Trek side
if somebody wanted to do Stargate versus
him yeah okay yeah I think it's good to
do Channel versus Channel and that sort
of thing and we'll we'll definitely
think about that but obviously things
like that take a little bit of time to
to um
organize
go suggest it to him too go suggest it
in Robert Meer Brett's comments yeah go
tell Robert yeah go tell him to to come
bugging us the ber networ the post geek
Singularity tell them they need to get a
little Sidetrack in their life you know
yeah because people love we need to get
David huet on
here anybody has got a link to him that
I can message him go ahead and I would
love to but um but yeah I will have a
word with our friends and a couple of
other channels and see if if we can get
something going all right um but I just
love arguing with you Harris because you
make it so
easy oh well
thanks uh stormy is still not very well
um he but he's on the menend guys he he
had um an infection in his in a bone so
we immediately obviously went boner um
um but Jenny sten's just become a member
of Sidra that's my
Jenny Jenny
um yeah love having J is amazing thank
you so much um but stormmy is on the men
he will be with us hopefully the next
week or two um he's on some quite heavy
medication at the moment so he can't
come on live because he talks like a
pissed bird know he's coming but um he's
he's he's really not very well so um but
he's getting better and he will be back
with us so um yeah he he's he's on the
menend he's on the menend that's the
main
thing send some love do Professor cringe
yeah so go go find him and um and Sayo
he'll he'll love that he's bored sat he
can't walk
around can't believe haven't done that
before well Jen we want we want your
time not your money really we want you
to come on and talk to us so right guys
say good night everybody and um we will
be back next week with us a hangout
probably
well good morning because it's only 11
over here but you
know good night good morning good
evening wherever the hell you are in the
world as we always start our videos Matt
with one t thank you so much for Modia
sir we'll see you next week and Harris
you were wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong
it
happened goodbye everybody see
y